You might imagine that faced with a large
defeat in the 2012 election, Donald Trump's
press secretary and senior campaign adviser,
Kayleigh McEnany, would be quietly preparing
to ride off into the sunset to some media
gigged some consulting gig somewhere.
Joe Biden is likely going to end up with three
hundred and six electoral votes, just like
Donald Trump had in 2016.
But unlike Donald Trump, who lost the popular
vote by three million, Joe Biden is on track
to win the popular vote by five, 5.5, maybe
even six million votes when all of the counting
is done.
But it's not stopping Kayleigh McEnany.
She will not stop humiliating herself.
And we're going to look at some clips today.
I'm wondering maybe whether there's a long
game that she's playing here, like maybe Carly
has the sense or she's been told, if you can
keep this up at some point in his next endeavor,
Donald Trump is going to give you a really
cushy gig gig, because, quite frankly, I don't
know how else we can understand why she's
behaving in this way.
Maybe I'm trying to apply logic where there
is no logic.
Let's see what you think after you see these
clips.
So to start with, last night, Donald Trump
and many Republicans were hopeful that Wayne
County in Michigan was not going to certify
their election results, just that one county.
And because the Trump campaign has had no
victories so far, speaking, you know, legal
victories, they were starting to say, wow,
Wayne County won't certify we won.
Here is Kayleigh McEnany cheering it with
Sean Hannity last night.
Wayne County canvassers say we cannot certify
this election because of these witnesses.
They're real people.
And one reporter tweeted out, this is the
first time in my 20 year history I've ever
seen something like this.
A county commission refused to certify its
because for the first time, you have a president
for fighting for the forgotten men and women
in Detroit and Philadelphia and Democrat cities
across the nation.
Now, unfortunately for her, these claims about
Wayne County were bogus.
And within minutes of Kayleigh saying this
to Sean Hannity, Wayne County did certify
the election as they should have.
And Michigan is now a closed book, essentially.
Then we go from talking about Michigan to
talking about Pennsylvania.
As you may have heard, Rudy Giuliani yesterday
went over the line from just being Donald
Trump's TV lawyer to actually arguing before
a court.
It reportedly was a huge embarrassment.
But here is Sean Hannity saying, I heard Rudy
was brilliant in court yesterday.
All right.
In Pennsylvania, Rudy Giuliani argued the
case today.
I've heard from more than.
A few people that he was absolutely brilliant
in his arguments today.
What's the status on that?
So the idea of Rudy being brilliant in court
at this point is hilarious.
And we later heard that Rudy made no sense
at all in court yesterday.
At one point, Rudy Giuliani apparently raised
the idea that some kind of mafia like organization
stole the election for Joe Biden in court,
Rudy Giuliani brought this up and it was reportedly
a legal embarrassment for Giuliani.
Let's continue.
Here is Kayleigh McEnany holding up papers
again.
It's almost a requirement.
Now, if you go on TV to argue that Joe Biden
stole the election, you have to hold up affidavits.
And Sean Hannity mentions this and says Kaili,
show them how the pages aren't really blank.
Like some people said, these papers, these
affidavits, two hundred thirty four pages
of sworn affidavits under penalty of perjury.
By the way, Kane County, what does CNN say
about when you held them up on this program?
Then they accuse you of holding up blank sheets?
That's right.
They did about a 10 minute monologue saying
these were blank.
They're not blank.
In fact, these pages of paper from one county
were the reason that you had a county level.
Wayne County canvassers say we cannot certify
this election because of these witnesses.
They're real people.
Now, of course, they did certify and the issue
isn't whether the pages are blank, it's that
the stuff on the pages is absolute and complete
nonsense.
So that was last night.
I think that last night she was senior campaign
adviser on the Sean Hannity program.
Now, this morning, Kelly went back on Fox
News, this time on Fox and Friends.
And today she was no longer Trump campaign
senior adviser.
Today she was White House press secretary.
And host Brian Kilmeade clarifies that this
is a game they play.
Thanks so much, Chris.
Meanwhile, let's bring in Kayleigh McEnany.
She's functioning with us today as the White
House press secretary.
So today she's White House press secretary
on Fox News.
Remember last week on Fox and Friends?
She was not White House press secretary last
week on Fox and Friends.
She was Trump campaign senior adviser.
So when they asked her questions about what
is Trump believe about this or that last week,
she said, oh, that really would be a question
for the White House, which, of course, she
is the spokesperson for the White House.
But last week she was not appearing in that
capacity.
The question here, it's completely Kafkaesque
is the way I would describe it here.
Kayleigh was asked about Donald Trump canceling
his Thanksgiving trip to his resort in Florida,
and Kayleigh frames it as he's hard at work.
Now, the truth is, Trump is in a bunker mentality.
He's not being seen in public.
Maybe he'll take questions today.
We've not seen him take questions for weeks
at this point in time.
But Kayleigh says he's just so hard at work
he's going to stay at the White House so quickly.
We know the president and Melania, the first
lady, are going to celebrate Thanksgiving
there at the White House.
And normally they go down to Mar a Lago and
they're going to pardon the turkeys, why they
decide to stay in D.C. this year.
All the president's hard at work.
He's hard at work on covid, among other issues,
are drawing down our number of troops in Afghanistan
and Iraq, bringing our men and women home.
He's hard at work on.
And so he's staying here at the White House.
And it will be a lovely Thanksgiving for him
and the first lady here in the White House.
All right.
Do you think we'll hear from the president
soon?
Perhaps that's up to President Trump.
You know, sometimes they'll make the decision
to come out on any given moment, but I'm sure
you'll hear from him at the right moment.
Now, Donald Trump has not been hard at work.
When you look at Donald Trump's schedule this
week, you see that he has had nothing on his
schedule other than golf and lunch with Mike
Pence.
And it's been weeks since he's taken any questions
from the media.
Just a couple more clips here.
Kaili dismisses the public health guidelines
about slowing the spread of coronavirus as
Orwellian when they bring up at Fox and Friends
the fact that we have cartoonishly high numbers
of coronavirus cases.
Well, but we know all across the country,
Kaili cases are spiking, unfortunately.
And this is the week before Thanksgiving when
families are going to be together.
And there are a number of governors who are
suggesting, look, you don't need to be in
a in a big group, particularly if people are
outside your bubble.
What do you think of these suggestions and
guidelines some of the governors have given
in advance of this because it is a super contagious
disease?
Yeah, I think a lot of the guidelines you're
seeing are Orwellian.
Let me start by saying the CDC has put out
considerations as we prepare to go about Thanksgiving,
about social distancing, wearing masks, doing
what you can.
And there's a whole list at page of very good
considerations.
And in that they say we're not recommending
a certain number of people, but we are giving
considerations that you should put in place.
It's Orwellian now to do what every sensible
country is doing.
That's really something.
And then.
Here, Kayleigh McEnany continues talking about
a second Trump administration, as if we're
just weeks from Donald Trump being sworn into
a second term job, a stockpile that was left
empty by Obama, Biden that he's filled up
since then.
He's left an infrastructure in place where
covid can be handled.
And we believe that we will do so going forward
in a second Trump administration.
All right.
OK, and I mean, yeah, there's not much else
to say about that.
And then lastly, of course, White House Press
Secretary Kayleigh McEnany will not commit
to a peaceful transfer of power.
If the president doesn't win and Joe Biden
is it's proven that he is the elected president,
what happens with the transfer of power?
Will it be peaceful?
Look, this president has always said he will
engage in a peaceful transfer of power if
the facts bear out that way.
But the president believes and so too do many
others that if every legal vote is counted,
he will remain president.
He's pursuing litigation.
But this president always wants what's in
the best interests of our country.
So day after day, another embarrassment, another
humiliation.
And I do hope that once Joe Biden selects
a press secretary for his administration,
the relationship between press secretary and
and the country will normalize.
It's been hysterical and histrionic during
the Trump administration.
It was that way with Sean Spicer.
Was there somebody there was somebody in between
Sarah Huckabee, Sanders, how could I forget?
And now with Kayleigh McEnany, it's been absolutely
ridiculous.
And hopefully we'll see something a little
bit more normal during the Joe Biden administration.
Follow us on Instagram for more on this and
other stories.
I'm on Instagram at David Pakman.
And you can also follow the show at David
Pakman, The David Pakman Show at David Pakman
dot com.